This is a special presentation of w n y c New York public
radio, opera. People are on that.
The ride of the Valkyrie is my theme song.
I'm trying to work it into my memorial service. I think you're [inaudible]
blur all nuts and what makes blogging rights special.
They're more not too more intense.
Probably some volume with more than that from
his desire to change his audience, not just to entertain them,
but to change them, to get inside of them and sturm up.
I just was so moved by that thing. This is what he was doing.
This is what he did and he succeeded. I could still just sing about, it.
Still makes me think of tear up, but you know
the man was an absolute horror when it came to stealing money,
stealing women, but he never wants compromised his artistic vision.
What I always tell people when they recoil at the idea of watching the ring or
other operas is these are mirrors of us.
When you see a lot of people making a huge fuss over work of art or an event or
a happening, you get curious.
The rain cycle is one of the biggest works of art ever created by one of the
most controversial artists to ever live.
Over the next hour we'll explore the question,
just what is this thing and why does it continue to inspire? Yeah.
[inaudible]
I'm Jack and Ron. This is the ring and I, The Passion and the myth, the mania.
Stay with us.
[inaudible]
so what is
the ring, if I had to describe it in one sentence,
it would go something like this.
The ring is a German romantic view of Norris and Teutonic myth influenced by a
Greek tragedy and a Buddhist sense of destiny told with the sociopolitical
deconstruction of contemporary society a psychological study of motivation and
action and a blueprint for a new approach to music and theater.
We'll get to all that. The first thing to know about Wagner,
his ring is that it is an event productions of the ring.
Seva will happen all over the world at different times,
but here in New York seems to rule through about once every four years like the
Olympics and when it does, the air changes,
people's eyes dilate and ring classes like this one, a Julliard,
a practically standing room only.
Okay, so let's begin the serious part of the class.
This is professor John Mueller. He stands by a piano in surveys, the 40 or so,
mostly older Wagner lovers who are lucky enough to make it into a seminar.
We're going to start with a quote,
and it may seem like an odd way to begin this class,
but when the third installment of the Lord of the rings trilogy came out,
they were doing a showing of all three of them.
They referred to this as the trilogy Tuesday and author of the article in the
Times made the comment
about you the need to see all three of them together. He says,
shouldn't all three movies be watched together?
Our forebears had Wagner's ring cycle.
We have Peter Jackson's Tolkien trilogy. I took offense to this statement,
a theatrical flourish.
Professor Muller flings a newspaper article away from him and discussed almost
hitting a student. Sorry about that.
[inaudible] is still very much with us and I don't think it's something just for
our forebearers and that statement really bothered me.
[inaudible] nonetheless. One of the reasons I,
and I would guess many people are curious about Buckner's ring now was because
of the Lord of the Rings Connection With the Lord of the rings for they could
not have existed in the form that that we know it now without vokner as an
example, according to New Yorker music critic Alex Ross,
there are the superficial connections like the way the characters dress and also
a lot of the language particular Wagnerian phrases,
a ride like a ride to ruin in the world's ending and those similarities he says
can be chucked up to ancient Norse mythology were both token and vokner got
their stories, but Wagner threw something new into the mix.
Which token borrowed outright a ring. This is the main connection.
This notion of this object which gives you power and it ultimately makes you
powerless. Ultimately you are a slave to it.
Yes,
the ring is very much with us and you know there are people who travel all over
the world going to wring cycles and I don't know,
maybe some of you are those people.
It's like the people who travel all over the world going to solar eclipses
wherever they may may happen.
We're talking about four operas here or one opera in four parts and it's 20
hours in all, but it's more than that too,
which was clear from John Mueller's class,
like a hobbit convention or a grateful dead tour. A ring cycle is an event.
It's a happening. It takes planning, so you'll need provisions.
That's where we had to fairway.
Fairway is Manhattan's biggest grocery store and when there's a ring in town
it's where you'll find Manhattan's biggest ring fan bread. Yes. Hey.
Hi Chad. Nice to meet you. Pleasure to meet you. Fred. Plot Kid.
He writes about food and opera and get,
this is on his 38th ring cycle.
This year I'll be seeing three ring cycles in different places I'm going to to
at the met with different casts and then I'm going to one in Finland.
My idea of creating a menu to dine while watching all four ring operas is to the
Beastie Maddick with the ring and inspired by the rain.
And I decided to look at the cycle and look for gastronomically queues of which
there are so many throughout the ring cycle of foods of food products.
He calls this the Wagner meal cycle.
He's able to tell the entire story of the ring through food and that's why we're
here for sustenance a,
I take doggy bags when I attend performances and meet them at the intermissions
and v because the plot of the ring cycle can get complicated fast.
And this is an easy way to remember what's happening on stage.
So Fred begins how the ring cycle begins with gold,
which we find it fairway in the chocolate aisle. John D,
your Yorkie are essential to the ring cycle because these are little gold wrap
nuggets of chocolate. They're like currency but hate like bricks of gold.
The first opera,
the Rheingold begins underwater at the bottom of the Rhine river.
We see three Ryan made in swimming around. They guard the gold.
All is fine with the world, says Fred, while the gold stays there.
That's you fundamental thing of the rain cycle.
When it's stolen theft and it's given away like taxes to the rich.
What happens is everything goes to skew and therefore we try to put the gold
back in the Ryan. It takes 20 hours to do it, but for the moment,
what we see on stage are Rhine maidens, swimming, she marine gold,
and what we hear is the orchestra building around the one e flat chord,
and this is where things get interesting. As John Muller tells his class,
this may be more than just pretty water music. In one sense,
the opening of the prelude is showing you the Rhine River from the very depths
of the Ryan when you get the opening e flat and the double basses then to higher
levels and more activity with our pzegeo figures in the strings,
but on a much deeper level.
Wagner is giving you creation itself and he represents this by using the
overtone series and other words we have in a sense the creation of tone from one
pitch, the birth of an entire universe as told in music.
Note by Note Adam by Adam,
which is why Professor Miller tells his students when they're in the audience
during the scene,
they may want to close their eyes going to burst out after more than three
minutes and you get the first ride.
Vaden entering who Glinda at initially she sings a couple of nonsense syllables
until she actually starts to speak the words the opera.
So it's as if Faulkner is also trying to convey the creation of speech
[inaudible]
this is just one indication buggers approach to drama is pretty wild on stage.
The eyes in our head are seeing Ryan maiden swimming while the eyes and our ears
are getting another image,
the cosmos being born and perhaps Wagner meant for our mind to somehow run to.
The question remains though,
how do you even get the first part right to visuals? This is opera members.
So along with music we've got the problem of staging
the ring is the biggest project. I think that any
opera house faces always. This is Joe Clark.
The Metropolitan Opera is technical director and we're on stage during a
changeover.
There's a challenge there that I don't think is like anything else too.
I write 4,000 empty seats to our left 60 some odd worker's swing hammers and
push props, and to my dismay for the swimming Ryan maiden scene,
he says they don't use an aquarium.
It's certainly not realistic water by any means. In fact,
it's very stylize,
but the whole proceeding was filled with a number of moving gauzes that are
painted to look like water. They're constantly in motion in their smoke,
dry eyes effects operating at the same time with fans scan,
it sort of seems like Colin sonder Warren and the three Rhine maidens.
Meanwhile, Joe has them stand on three separate stage lifts,
which move up and down, but very slowly so you,
you get that sense of water flowing.
We'd heard that the Seattle opera takes it a bit further.
So we called director Speight Jenkins.
His company has taken the Rhine maidens to new heights.
Literally they suspend the singers 25 feet off the ground.
[inaudible]
well, it looks like [inaudible] is what it does. The first time I saw it,
I almost dropped because you see, first of all,
we dress them in kind of mermaid ish type things. Wonderful wigs.
It looks as though the, it's a very fluid and easy movement. They can go down.
In other words, they can go down and they can spin.
Now what makes it unusual is that they do in fact flip as they seem
[inaudible]
the three young women at first were,
you know a little bit nervous about that as the,
as we moved on into rehearsals and got to the provinces,
they flipped all the time as they saying, they would flip on singing. High note
[inaudible]
very good. You don't put it into [inaudible].
This voice right here, that's where the trouble starts.
[inaudible]
this is al the evil dwarf. He shows up at the bottom of the Ryan,
starts to chase the Rhine maidens round and round.
They laugh at him.
Then he steals their gold and forges a ring that will make him master of the
universe.
Eventually the gods steal it from him and the world begins to go south.
Fun.
Wagner, his musical universe really starts to take off.
[inaudible]
for more on that we visit pianist Jeffrey Swan.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate it.
Jeffrey Swan lectures all over the country about the ring and in particular on a
system Wagner developed called light motif.
It's as if he gave each character a theme and then change those teams as the
characters change.
He demonstrates as we sit at a grand piano that takes up almost as entire
midtown apartment.
The ideal listener to the ring early on needs
to become aware, I suppose of leitmotifs a real obvious one.
When we hear the, um, the Rhine maidens and the very first scene, um,
when they're singing their song of joy and they say, Ryan Gold, Ryan Gold
[inaudible]
they sing it over and over again.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
at the end of the work,
we hear the ride main sort of off stage and now there'd be wailing their fate as
it were because they've lost the gold,
lost their gold and the gods aren't giving it back to them.
[inaudible]
here it's something concrete, a change of harmony.
The fact that the orchestration is completely different.
There's just a harp on stage, the difference
[inaudible]
but this is just the tip of the iceberg. It gets much, much,
much more complicated with Jeffrey because often Wagner will use light motifs to
comment on the action. What a foreshadow,
and this is something film composers have eagerly embraced. I mean,
just imagine if the Rhine maidens are swimming and you hear this in the
orchestra,
you know immediately what's about to happen to them.
It seems obvious, right? But think about how powerful this is. Just two notes.
Create the image of a big fish in your mind,
which brings us back to Lord of the Rings
[inaudible]
and Oscar winning composer Howard shore.
Howard,
if I were to call your scores for the Lord of the Rings Movies Wagnerian not
saying I would, but if I were to call it that,
you would think what I would think like Motif, music,
expressing emotional ideas and the use of leitmotifs.
Is that something you made use of in your score? Oh, I think tremendously.
How so? Well, there's over 50 and fatigue. Oh, really? Used in the piece, uh,
didn't reflect each individual character by they reflect, uh,
characters and places and objects.
The ring itself has four motifs for its different moods.
And here's the one you may recognize if you've seen the movies.
[inaudible]
just seems like a good time to ask the question. Why a ring?
This was something token borrowed from Wagner, but where did Wagner get it from?
And what does it mean? Hi, it's
Chad and w and Y, Z e right there.
So we visited Lori Shapira in her small offices.
Brooklyn. Laurie, Shakira is a union analyst,
also teaches a class about north Smith
volunteering and symbolism in the ringside. Well, first of all,
the ring is made of gold. It's made of the gold.
So it's manufactured. And I think that's an important piece of this.
[inaudible]
gold is a treasure, right? But in its raw state,
it's perhaps worthless in a way.
Only valuable if it's made into something else.
That's a very western concept.
A person who is willing to renounce love and who has the skill to forge the gold
into a ring,
we'll be able to have measureless might is the way it reads the libretto reads.
It's a very modern idea. New Yorker music critic Albatross.
It's not something that a,
the old story tellers seem to think about any random person in be able to,
to pick up an object and automatically, uh, have power over everything. It just,
it wasn't part of their, their way of looking at the world.
Power wasn't infinitely transferrable.
Those who had power were born with power and those who didn't, uh, you know,
would never be able to touch it.
You know, he wrote this around the middle of that of the 19th century.
Wagner wrote the ring in the same year that Marx wrote the communist manifesto
and there was a revolution going on.
There was something in the air we could view that as perhaps the real dawn of
the age of [inaudible].
No, what that means is open to interpretation,
but Lori Shapira defines it as the beginning of the end.
Destructive technology was on the horizon.
Kings and queens were being replaced by new belief systems.
Wagner was creating a mythology for these uncertain times with the ring of power
at the center, a symbol of both what's possible and what might be missing.
It's a,
it's a myth that appears apparently at around the same time that coins were
invented, Pulitzer Prize winning playwright, Tony Kushner and it,
and it has always stood on some level for the invention of money,
the transfiguring power of gold in that it's a f,
it's an invisible force.
I mean the ring is always the thing that makes you invisible and unseen so that
it can be there and not be there or what's the thing in our lives that's there
and not there at the same time that has immense power but is essentially
invisible. It's the power of money.
[inaudible].
Speaking of money,
my first opera ends with the gods and marching triumphantly into their new
castle. Valhalla built by giants and paid for with stolen gold
block and explains it's a real estate deal and the the gold is stolen by Al
Brick. The dwarf and then is taken by vote Tom,
the chief God who gives it to the giants factor and facile for their laborers to
build Valhalla. Yeah. How do you get to this great big castle?
You have to build a rainbow bridge. It takes energy to do that.
So what do you eat? Rainbow Trout. And that's what we're going to do.
See if they have rainbow trout
coming up. Incest apocalypse now in a ring of fire,
you are listening to a special presentation from wny scene,
New York public radio, the ring and I, The Passion, the myth, the mania.
I'm Jad Abumrad
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
I'm Janet Rod.
This is a special presentation from W and y c New York public radio,
the ring and I, The Passion, the myth, the mania.
It's amateur night cafe Tochi uptown.
This place we've been told is where professional opera singers hang out after
performances and also where three times a week up and comers strut their stuff.
This is one of those nights and we're hoping to see something from the ring
cycle to use in this documentary, but this Guy Brian Griffin, flat out refuses.
I could never sing the ring in my life no matter what I do.
I just don't have that kind of voice. I mean it's the epitome of singers,
dumb things. That's a word.
Another aspiring singer takes the stage and let's rip some Italian opera.
Well, I head to the back to join a table of dramatic files.
Includes rock guitars, Gary Lucas, formerly at the band captain Beefheart.
Let's just say that some of the classic led Zap rifts could be considered
Wagnerian. Can you give specific examples? I wonder celebs have. Okay,
let's go to the very first led. Zep Hits whole lot of love. You know,
it's got this motif
and that motif is really hammered home.
This is a special presentation of w n y c New York public radio
opera. People are all nuts.
The ride of the Valkyrie is my theme song.
I'm trying to work it into my memorial service. I think your point was all nuts.
Then what makes Wagner rights special? There are more, not too more intent,
probably on volume with more than
[inaudible] [inaudible] desire to change his audience,
not just to entertain them, but to change them,
to get inside of them and stir them up. I just was so moved by that thing.
This is what he does do. This is what he did and he succeeded.
I could still just think about it still makes me kind of [inaudible]
but you know
the man was an absolute horror when it came to stealing money,
stealing women, but he never wants compromised his artistic vision.
What I always tell people when they recoil it,
the idea of watching the ring or other operas is these are mirrors of us.
[inaudible].
When you see a lot of people making a huge fuss over a work of art or an event
or a happening, you get curious.
The ring cycle is one of the biggest works of art ever created by one of the
most controversial artists to ever live.
This is a special presentation of w n y c New York public radio
opera people are all nuts.
The ride of the Valkyrie is my theme song.
I'm trying to work it into my memorial service. I think it was blur all nuts.
Then what makes Wagner rights special? They're more nuts and more intense,
probably on volume of more than [inaudible].
His desire to change his audience, not just to entertain them,
but to change them, to get inside of them and stuff.
This is a special presentation of w n y c New York public radio
opera people are all nuts.
Well, the right of the Valkyrie is my theme song.
I'm trying to work it into my memorial service. I think you're blur all nuts.
Then what makes blogging rights special?
There are more nuts and more intense probably because volume is more than
[inaudible].
It's desire to change his audience,
not just to entertain them, but to change them,
to get inside of them and stir them up. I just was so moved by that thing.
This is what he was doing. This is what he did and he succeeded.
I could still just sing about it. Still makes me kind of, but you know,
the man was an absolute horror when it came to stealing money,
stealing women that he never wants compromised his artistic vision.
What I always tell people when they recoil it,
the idea of why human ring or other operas is these are mirrors of us.
[inaudible] when
you see a lot of people making a huge fuss over a work of art or an event or a
happening, you get curious.
The ring cycle is one of the biggest works of art ever created by one of the
most controversial artists to ever live. Over the next hour,
we'll explore the question,
just what is this thing and why does it continue to inspire? [inaudible]
[inaudible]
I'm Jack and Rob. This is the ring and I the passion, the myth, the mania.
Stay with us.
[inaudible]
so what is the ring? If I had to describe it in one sentence,
it would go something like this.
The ring is a German romantic view of Norris and Teutonic myth,
influenced by a Greek tragedy and a Buddhist sense of destiny,
told with the sociopolitical deconstruction of contemporary society a
psychological study of motivation and action and a blueprint for a new approach
to music and theater. But we'll get to all that.
The first thing to know about Wagner is ring is that it is an event,
productions of the ring. Siva will happen all over the world at different times,
but here in New York seems to rule through about once every four years left the
Olympics. When it does, the air changes,
people's eyes dilate in wind classes like this one,
a Juilliard practically standing room only twins.
Arthur Wilbarger explains,
we have two lonely people who are these twin brother and sister parted at birth.
And there's always been a sense of something missing in their lives.
They've had rotten, miserable lives, both of them.
And then they meet and he says something that I think is so powerful.
He says to best us, Bill, you are the image that I've kept hidden in myself.
[inaudible]
and that's why he loves her. And I think that's,
that's a beautiful moment for anybody who's ever had any kind of a, um,
a coming out process coming out as anything coming out as a full human. Yeah.
Being incest as self-discovery. Sound crazy. Hello
Metaphor. If we're not capable of metaphor,
you're probably going to have a lot of trouble at the opera anyway.
Or the movies will says, just think of all the cinematic incest out there.
Princess Leia Skywalker, back to the future. Cruel intentions. House of yes.
Oedipus rex dangerously as well.
This is a myth that speaks to our primitive brains, says writer and commentator,
John Rockwell,
the deepest archetypal needs and longings of a given culture.
And these are common across cultures.
And so almost every culture has an incest love story or a heroic hero who
defeats a fearsome enemy.
I'm selfless.
The heroic hero and fearsome enemy coming our next opera for now,
back to the family drama vote the head
God and dad of this dysfunctional family has to figure out what to do about the
ancestors. Twins. He does love the twins. They are his kids after all.
But what they are doing is illegal and immoral.
He tells his daughter Brunello to go get Sigmund and bring him to Valhalla.
In other words, kill him. She agrees and shows up at Sigmund's house,
but finds that he doesn't want to come as far as she's concerned. It's like, hi,
come on, let's go to Valhalla. It's really great,
which you can't understand why he wouldn't want to go.
But when he explained it to her,
she then starts to understand what he explains to her.
Such Jane is that he's in love.
He'd rather stay here on earth with his sweetheart than go up to Valhalla,
no matter how glorious it is up there. And that totally flips her.
She's never seen true love before and it makes her question everything.
Should she even kill this guy? Or God Forbid Disobey Her Dad. [inaudible]
Arthur will Wilbert jury. So on the one hand we have these, um,
[inaudible] fairy tale, let's say fairy tale characters,
but I think what is really superb about the ring,
they're real people to real characters go through real emotions.
And the fact that they happened to be gods is kind of immaterial in a sense
because what you've got here says Jane is a story anyone can relate to a story
about him growing up and becoming independent,
and that's why she loves this role because of the development that you get.
And that comes through the music as well as through the character and the drama.
Speaking of the music in Wagner, the music knows everything,
even when the characters don't know what's going to happen. Music does this.
We found out from Jeffery Swan,
we're back in his small apartment with a giant piano for another demonstration.
He explains that Votan carries a giant spear wherever he goes.
The spear stands for vote on his power.
His legal power is his power to rule the world.
And the spirit he says has a musical motif. The whole opera of era is sort of,
could be,
could be experienced strictly as or policed as a exercise and what happens to
the spear motive? In other words,
what happens to photons authority over his daughter.
He demonstrates starting with the original Motif, the spirit
[inaudible] [inaudible]
from that spear motive. You get something like [inaudible].
[inaudible],
[inaudible]
C. Yeah.
I can't hear the different there. Deconstruct it for you. You can.
Can you give me like a 32nd deconstruct? Sure. The spirit motive,
let's put it in there. Their convenience.
[inaudible]
scale rhythmic going down. Okay. First thing, let's put it in the major
instead of continuing down, let's jump back on ourselves.
Slow it down.
[inaudible]
hi
[inaudible].
This was an epiphany. The one thing anyone can hear in Wagner is rings flux.
It's unstable music,
huge masses of sound swirling endlessly like waves and yet inside that flux
there is a center. You feel it.
Millions of musical cells multiplying, mutated,
make up the 18 hour organism that is doing cycle,
each cell attached to a character idea.
All these characters and ideas and constant states of change like what we're
listening to now, just one of those cells, a spear. Meredith,
a symbol of photons, power and authority transform.
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible]
analyst, Laura Shapiro.
The main conflict in the in the ring is love versus power.
Now it would be easy to say, well,
the power guys are the bad guys and the love guys are the good guys in the
world,
but we all have inside of us a power drive and arrows.
Really the most important way of interpreting is to look at it psychologically
that all of these characters are part of the individual are parts of the
personality that are in conflict so that the deepest way to interpret this
conflict between love and power is to find it in one south.
Brunhilda is often referred to as vote.
Hahn's will is if there are two parts of the same person.
Photon had ordered her to kill the boy twin because he felt bound to by law.
He disobeyed his orders but fulfilled his true wishes.
They meet on a mountain top and he decides for punishment,
which brings us back to Fred family.
Rutan Hilda is photons favorite daughter and she shows up,
does battle disagrees with her father who he loves and these are intolerant
times and though he says, I love you, he says, have to put you to sleep.
And so he kisses your eyes shut in a very tender scene.
Suddenly he creates a fire.
[inaudible]
[inaudible], [inaudible]
[inaudible].
It's kind of like the fires of the southwest.
I know the president talks about his clean forest initiative when he should see
this and then what you have is this incredible fire that protects Brunhilda.
It never burns her so that only a great hero can penetrate the fire to wake her
up and she's leaving for 18 years. So when she wakes up, boy is she hungry.
So I created rock shrimp,
Colombia because she's many liters, seems in the ring, can seem hokey.
But this moment at the end of the Valkyrie where photon gently kisses Buena,
his eyes to sleep is one of the most famous and most widely loved the entire
cycle
soprano, Jane Eaglin. My father died very young.
So the whole sort of father domes relationship is something which is very much
in my mind.
The idea of never seeing your father again is something that I can certainly
relate to.
Occasionally there have been times in a Valkyrie performance when I have
actually felt, you know,
tears welling up just because you get so into the moment. I mean,
I do think that the Photon Front Hilda scene at the end of the Carrie is like
the greatest father daughter scene ever written playwright Tony Kushner.
It's so mu, I mean it's so moving.
The music is so heartbreaking and the things that they say to each other,
deep stubborn and love that they have for each other kind of it,
it's in dialectical tension to, to uh,
the way that everything else breaks under the spell of the goal.
That this is an this kind of connection that it simply cannot be severed.
[inaudible]
you are listening to a special presentation from W NYC,
New York public radio that ring and I, The Passion, the myth, the mania.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible],
um, Jab and Ron, this is a special presentation from w NYC,
New York public radio, the ring and I, The Passion, the myth, the mania.
There are certain facts about Wagner that get repeated over and over.
However unbelievable. Here's one.
There are more books on Wagner than anyone except Christ.
That was Dorothy Pepe, the American Wagner Association.
We called the library of Congress. They couldn't verify it, right? It is true,
and every week there's another book on Wagner.
One thing is for sure though, if Wagner is second to God,
he wouldn't be pleased. He thought he was God and like it or not,
he created a work in the ring cycle that is like the Bible.
It's open to an infinity of interpretations, not all good.
It would be very easy to interpret the ring in terms of politics,
let's say analyst and historian,
Lori Shapira looking at different groups of people,
the new belongs or the gods to sort of assign them to different ethnic groups.
Perhaps Hitler was loved doing that.
For instance, imagine how the third opera,
the ring cycle might look through the eyes of the Third Reich.
It's called Siegfried and it begins with an r
[inaudible],
the one side Siegfried,
the muscular blue eyed child of glory on the other Mima a sniffling,
crafty dwarf. The dwarf is the boys of Guardian.
Lima found him abandoned in the forest, raised him, but now sick feed is dying
to get away. [inaudible]
playwright Tony Kushner. I mean, Mimi
has sort of, you know,
this repulsive whining fetch is on one level that you're supposed to sort of
sneer at him as this person who slept in prison.
Siegfried in this like false domesticity and that he has to be there.
You have to throw off the chains of this terrible Jew who was like your neighbor
longer, whatever you want to call him. This wonder man,
she was like clinging to you so that you can go off and be the hero.
But of course that isn't really the experience. I mean,
what's really great about Siegfried is that it's like a fantastic portrait of
this abs and you and you know, Wagner intended it.
It's like one of the most marvelous portraits of a teenage germ
[inaudible]
you know, those scenes between him and Mimi are just fantastic.
it's not to say that Wagner didn't hate Jews. He did in an early essay,
he called Jews worms and freaks of nature.
It's not that you're unaware of the fact that this is a great racial
nationalist,
epic written by an antisemitic ego maniacal monster,
but it's just too great to leave alone.
[inaudible]
what we've got here is the most universal story known to man a hero's journey.
like star wars. You've got to sword much like a Lightsaber,
a boy looking for his parents, interesting creatures,
some insects they're in for good measure.
[inaudible]
Siegfried, it turns out as the child of the twins from our last opera,
oh [inaudible]
and as writer Fred Block and explains back at fairway,
our hero has got a lot of growing up to do.
And really Siegfried the opera is the education of Siegfried.
Sort of a coming of age story, right? Coming of age story. Uh,
Ashton Kutcher would do it now it's probably option than writing I think.
So Fred Parallels,
sig frees ring journey with his own gastronomic one by ordering up a filet of
swordfish. He goes from being a callow, you getting an education,
literally sort of trials by fire.
And the first fire is actually the forging of the soar,
which is wonderful music.
[inaudible].
Once he's created the sword,
he learns how to use it and he discovers that fastener.
Remember factor the giant theft and the giant we met in the first opera,
he built the gods a castle and exchange for the Rheingold.
He's been holding onto the gold for all these hours.
Now the gold includes the ring.
Whoever has the ring is master of the universe, but the ring has a curse on it,
so he who takes something that's not rightfully is like taking the Whitehouse
when you didn't win, pays the consequences. As you can see,
the story is so archetypal that anyone can see what they want. Well,
manages the giants as Republicans. Tony Cushner prefers the Marxist review.
I mean,
it's essentially a socialist parable, which queens?
The giants with the working class.
It's gigantic in Kuwait forest that you know that's been promised a share in
divinity. In any case, after the giant is no longer at giant.
When he got his hands on the ring, he turned himself into a dragon.
[inaudible]
he singing dragon, not your typical Lord of the Rings Dragon.
He's sometimes depicted as a sad creature woozy. When the power of the ring
here again, interpretations vary.
[inaudible] dragons are always in the ring. Cute. Speight Jenkins,
the Seattle opera. So I said, I want to have a dragon that is truly scary.
Okay, fine. We thought, well let's have a dragon bigger than the opera house.
And so we only see his clothes. Well, a was a bad idea.
And B,
it was an idea that I didn't think through and nobody else did either because
Siegfried supposed to send him in the heart.
So how on earth do you stab him in the heart if you don't see a heart?
We didn't. How did you not think of that? I don't know. But we didn't.
So then we moved on to dragon number two,
[inaudible]
Greg. And number two was a dragon seven feet tall.
And this was a beautifully conceived dragon high-flow.
It was a old locomotive with a steam shovel for a face.
Really?
It came on stage led by stage hands all dressed in black and it puffed steam and
out of the steam shovel blew huge amounts of fire. Wow.
And the audience went totally crazy over it. When he was stabbed,
all of the smoke died,
all of the fire died and all of the stage hands who had a chance to be real
hands all fell to the stage dead at that moment.
[inaudible]
after the dragon six read has an even bigger challenge when Hilda remember her,
she's been asleep for 18 years on a mountain surrounded by a ring of fire,
secrete comes along to wake her up sort of a snow white sleeping beauty
situation.
He was friend.
We could also say that the whole progression of the cycle is not just the
consequences of the ring but the growth of Brunhilda from a Sassy young woman,
a goddess full of Piss and vinegar to use a food term or ginger lets say when
she's been put to sleep for 18 years,
he is awakened as a mortal rice soprano.
Jane Egan means it becomes more dramatic I think as the cycle goes on.
Really she's discovering her womanly qualities and falling in love.
She's no longer a goddess and doesn't have the power he had and therefore
develops as a human.
And this is what is so fundamental to understanding the ring cycle
that gods are not infallible.
Mortals have great power and glory if they know how to use it and they become
the best that they can as human beings.
[inaudible]
is Wagner approached the end of the ring cycle,
which took him 25 years to write a few things began to dawn on him. First,
the theater, no theater in the world would be able to stage this. A dragon,
a ring of fire. It was getting too big. What to do. Well,
first he tried to redesign the city of Munich around the ideal opera house that
he would need in order to present this the right way. Okay.
Do you know any artists like this? It wasn't simple. Vanity driving and says,
well Berger,
Faulkner wanted the opera house to redeem the world and like Siegfried,
he thought it was up to him. Yes,
it was very like the the artist as savior of humanity.
What he wanted to save humanity from was fragmentation. In today's world.
You've got art over here in politics over here in philosophy and religion over
there. Bob, you wanted them all together in one glorious mind, altering fusion,
a festival which would last for four days,
and then in this wonderful idea he had at the end of these four days,
you just burned the structure to the ground because you're burning man kind of
situation. Burning man, totally burning man.
Burning man incidentally is an annual art gathering in the Nevada desert that
ends with the burning of a giant wooden statue.
The entire community dancing around it in some way,
praising all the art that had gone into it.
That's symbolic renewal like burning man.
It would have to be outside the bounds of civilization.
You'd have to travel long distances to get there. Leave your life behind.
The place he chose was a small town in Germany called by Roy King built him a
theater specifically to stage the ring cycle and that theater and the town
remained to Wagner divo teas. The promised land, the Hodge,
the most intense experience I've ever seen of real desperation was going to buy.
Right and seeing people try to get in right are in commentator John Rockwell
some. It is so, so, so hopelessly, so loud.
There's this desperate cadre of people holding up signs saying zero quit,
s, u, c, h, e,
which means looking for tickets and I was one of those people in the summer of
1959 or 60 I really feel like it's just stepping into an alternate universe.
New Yorker, music critic, Alex Ross, you're, you're living in, in,
in Wagner's world. It's like a vacation inside a work of art.
I don't know how to describe it.
It was only about these operas and so nothing else was going on.
And you sit around talking with these fanatics of which you are one
about about Wagner and about the experience and about the performance and
whether it was any good and it was good and it wasn't good.
I've just never experienced anything like that. I mean,
when you go to the opera at the met, are there any other urban opera house?
You Go, you're in its world for a few hours and then when you leave,
you get subway, you'd go home. You know the bills are there.
Now this is perhaps obsessive, but it is devotion. I mean,
you know,
people make fun of the romantic image of the artist as kind of mad men who are
above the normal range of human experience and have some direct connection with
the divine and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And it's very easy in our modern politically correct age to mock that all said,
Wagner wrote the book and I'm being a medic artist.
I mean he was more brilliant and more talented and more close to divine
inspiration than most other people. And when you hear his music, you hear that?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
we pick up the action with sick Freen Brunhilda on the mountain,
right where we left him. Sick feet puts the ring of power on her finger.
They embrace. If we were to stop the story right here, we'd have a happy ending.
The ring of power becomes a wedding ring. Love conquers all.
And Wagner considered going this route but then scrapped it because somewhere
along the way,
his outlook on life changed from Utopian to Dystopian and that's exactly what we
get in this final opera. Very large doses of things falling
[inaudible].
That's why it's called the twilight of the gods.
Brunhilda send Siegfried off on an adventure. Well, back at fairway.
Fred Plotkin
grabs the package of rings off the shelf and explains the trouble that lies
ahead. The one major character that we've not really spoken about yet is Haagen.
He's the son of Al Brick who put the curse on the ring a long time ago and
Haagen is the bad guy.
He's the one who plots to Duke Siegfried by taking him away from Brunhilda Hilda
and introducing him to a woman named good Taroona. Good Bitch.
I'm not kidding if Siegfried is dude, he's given drugs.
The classic love potion,
he forgets about his wife and falls in love with another woman.
He has betrayed when Hilda and she will betray him right back.
He's just not swift and ultimately will be due by lots of people in.
That's his great cry.
[inaudible]
maybe being a heroic hero is as much about being stupid as being courageous.
In any case, sick freed is clueless.
The only character or theme that has any clue in this world is the music.
Remember how Wagner created little musical themes for his characters and
objects. We'll listen to how he uses them and just looking at this.
I see so many
things. Look at so many references. We're back at pianos.
Jeffrey Swan's Manhattan apartment.
When we turned to a random page from the final opera, so we have,
that interval has to do with Haagen and there's the smear.
Here's a new motive of the blood brotherhood.
It's related to the nibble on this.
Actually the torx dwarfs that and forging.
Would that have to stop a second?
That was a Goo Truda and friendship and the fire.
They're going to go [inaudible].
This is back to the blood brotherhood again.
It's going to get complicated in seconds.
That's friendship and that's Haagen. There's this sphere again,
this is complicated. Definitely you have to follow any of this.
People like Jeffrey Swan have spent their lives trying to decode it all.
It still can vary because maybe Wagner didn't intend it to make literal sense.
You might imagine it like this. I think,
I mean when you're walking down the street just live in your life.
Your brain is firing off all of these thoughts. Half thoughts, really. Wow.
Cute dog and my fat. Hmm Relativity, what am I going to wear tonight?
I'd like that song. Who am I?
All of these things you're thinking but not conscious of thinking.
If everyone else on the street is doing that too.
When you could somehow collected all,
you'd have a gurgling churning pool of longings and yearnings.
Recruit would later give this a name, the collective unconscious,
and that says Jeffrey Swan is what Wagner was doing with the instruments of his
orchestra, trying to reflect the subconscious emotional life of his characters.
Now how much does does, does a casual listener pick up of this?
I think he picks up some of it actually that could fairway,
as Fred explains things with sick feet are about to take a turn for the
[inaudible].
He's taken on a hunting trip. All the guys are going out,
you know, and there was swords and Siegfried has his sword,
but he's briefly described it in Hoggins tabs him in the back.
This goes back to your Rome, if not before that,
but Siegfried is step. Siegfried is superhuman,
but he has one weak spot on his back.
And the real tragedy here is that it was brewed. Hilda told Haagen about it.
She was blinded with rage over secretes betrayal and they carry him back to the
castle. And there's this gorgeous music. Gorgeous.
It's um, the funeral music,
the Ryan Kearney and funeral music is they take him back. His,
some of the most glorious music ever written.
[inaudible]
Brunhilda now in the land of humans,
sees the body and her anger turns to sadness.
She realizes what brought about this treachery
Brando JD.
At one point she said that another wonderful life in the room, she says,
now I know everything.
I know. I understand everything. I know everything.
She has to give the ring back to the Ryan Dye, but everything will be fine.
Wow. It's almost like she becomes the hero then. Oh, totally.
[inaudible]
six [inaudible] are tragic,
not so bright here out turned out to be a deacon all along a woman comes
through. In the end, Carl Yoon saw this as Wagner critiquing patriarchal rule.
What the audience sees are supposed to see something that has tortured technical
directors like Joe Clark for a hundred years.
[inaudible]
a lot happens in a very short time. I'm listed as long.
We're at the metropolitan opera again this time underneath the stage,
Joe explains his technique for destroying the world,
which involves setting an entire stage above us on elevators and then at the
point of collapse, the elevators themselves are moving down at the same time,
elements of that scene were coming upon a he, you can create this sort of,
no one would've ever thought to try this before Wagner,
which is why the is sometimes called Prodo cinema movies. However,
the music supports the visual.
Here it says Joe and music is out front with the visuals hanging on for dear
life. The way I often measure it or this does say I do it, does it?
Does it look like it sounds and if you can get something in the ring to look
like the ring sounds,
it's sounding like one of the most remarkable things in the history of western
art and you can get something to look like that sounds.
It's quite wonderful in the theater in Wagner, his head,
it all happens in one astonishing moment.
When Hilda light secretes funeral pyre throws herself in it,
flames sees the stage and ball Holla, the of the gods collapses
[inaudible]
then the Rhine River overflows its banks and the Rhine maidens come swimming by
to reclaim the ring
for the first time since the beginning of the cycle.
The balance in the universe is your store
[inaudible]
the ring cycle was Wagner trying to put his arms, the world and compass
everything. Thousands of years in mythology said to extraordinary music
and yet at the center of all that huge, it's just us up there.
People trying to be knowable, joint possibility failing.
That's the surprising thing from a guy who thought he was gone.
We get a story about how the gods must die,
and maybe this is what it means to say things about.
And not just that you try to save everything,
but it will try even though you know you ultimately can't.
Thug nurse music can express more than any of us can.
It's perhaps the most important thing I can say to you. Now. Listen,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
during and I was produced by me and Aaron Cohen with production assistance from
Michael Raytheon, Jenny Schneier and Max Leper,
an executive producer is Elena Park. Special thanks to Dean Capella,
George Preston, Margaret jump. Wait. Michael l Sesar, Sarah Billinghurst,
Ellen Godfrey,
and the staff of the Metropolitan Opera King FM studios in Seattle and engineer
Bill Sigmund.
This program was made possible by the listeners of w and y c New York
[inaudible] from Jonathan Ryan.